i'm just going to wear that jacket
[Laughter]
oh really i didn't realize that you were
rustling cattle now
all right let's do this my guest tonight
is an emmy award-winning actor who of
course played sam malone
on cheers and he has a recurring role on
curb your enthusiasm
i'm not mentioning a million other
brilliant things currently you can see
him
on the nbc series mr mayor which is
hilarious please welcome our friend
ted danson how are you ted i'm good
conan
i'm good uh quickly before we get
started i decided uh to wear this
jaunty scarf today be honest
is this working for me or not you can
just you know feel free to
it is and you can get away with it
because
you know i wear it at my age people
think oh he's trying to cover his
wrinkly neck
you it's just jaunty me it's unfortunate
i have a high def screen your neck's
looking fine uh i wouldn't worry about
that i've met some celebrities who
definitely need to wear a scarf we won't
go into names
but um i want to mention something to
you which is
i'm on my way to work today here at the
largo theater
and to talk to you and i'm going through
my head and i'm thinking every time i've
had
an interaction with you you've been
unfailingly nice
and you have that reputation i think you
and tom hanks both have it of
such sweet guys such nice guys and i'm
convinced that deep down there's some
evil there
there's some there's some satanic evil
inside you i know there has to be
well i can't speak for tom that could
well be
it is true for tom it is true it's true
yeah for me
it's more of a case of uh superficiality
you uh basically what you're saying is
that there's a thin patina of niceness
around you with very thin coating
yeah you know i'm i'm the word for me is
charming
yeah now my wife my wife is nice yes
and nice means and kind means that you
tell the truth
you uplift people in a deep
life-changing kind of way
yeah i will just make you smile in the
moment
and then you move on before they can
scratch any deeper
or before they realize i don't remember
their name
[Laughter]
ted you don't even know who who i am
right now but you're doing a great job
of pretending
mary can always tell when i have no idea
who i'm talking to
because of the the big hug i give them
if you hug them
clearly i must know your name right
right right you don't know them uh
what do you like okay because you are
one of the most
recognizable faces in the world some
celebrities
are known for being they kind of have a
difficult persona
and that keeps people at bay you know
and uh and i would think that there that
would be a a great
boon to someone who could just i don't
know like a
like a jack nicholson you know where you
think
he might be a good guy but you're not
sure
so people probably leave them alone you
on the other hand
i would think people walk up to you all
the time because
they know you from all these roles where
you're very accessible
what you're saying basically is i don't
have an ounce of dangerous sexuality in
me
at all that's it that's that's that's it
on the nose
[Laughter]
well my favorite my favorite come up and
talk to me
uh was in new york i was coming out of
some restaurant in soho it was lunchtime
and i was by myself and some guy went
hey
and i turned around to be my charming
shallow self
and he uh he looked at me and he said
hey ted you remember that time i watched
you on tv
you know it was like
oh okay maybe i should move on yeah but
i gave him i had this standard thing
that it works in airports bars
you know wherever which is i had this
generic
chortle slash chuckle laugh
kind of thing uh and it goes like it's
very simple it's just
hey hey you know yeah it's a bit of a
winnie like
a horse yeah but uh what it does is it
says
oh i'm with you buddy you know i totally
get you
yeah we're one of the same you know it
gives all of those things with just uh
hey without too much of an expenditure
of effort
on your part no no uh yeah i have a
thing
where the thing i get when i go anywhere
is
i'm taller than people think even when
people know that i'm tall
i'm taller than people think i'm going
to be because they're used to seeing me
you know all these years and then and i
think i have the personality of a very
small person and um so i get all the
time
hey conan you uh you're bigger than you
look on tv you much
you know and and you look much smaller
on television
and i'll say you need a bigger tv
and they laugh and my kids are with me
and they'll say you use that you use
that line
and i'll say what are you talking about
i have to do i have to talk to 10 000
people a day
i'm going to reuse the line occasionally
okay i'm going to it works and i'm going
to reuse it and they're totally like
nope you've lost my respect you did that
you did that yesterday at the burger
lounge and i'm like i don't care it
worked there and it worked here
you know what is nice is that you're
getting to show on curb your enthusiasm
you're getting to show this side of you
where you can be impatient with larry
you can be
you can be angry with larry you can
disagree with her you can be
mean to larry and it's appropriate
because larry
deserves it let's face it absolutely
and i think that's your job people talk
about you know
are you playing yourself or a version of
you know you have
you're a function you're not a character
on curb you're a function and your
function is to
drive uh larry into a corner
until he gets so you know tight that he
comes out exploding
yes he comes out more larry more
inappropriate
more whatever so that it's basically the
same when you go out to dinner with them
you know you just first off he's so
generous
with his laughter in real life a lot of
stand-ups aren't that way yeah a lot of
stand-ups are kind of no no
i make the jokes kind of thing he
loves you to be funny and loves to laugh
at his
his own expense so you basically even
going out to dinner you try to find ways
new ways of insulting him and making him
laugh
which is pretty much the same thing you
do when you go to work the
uh thing that's weird about larry that i
don't think a lot of people know
is that he'll meet you for dinner but
not not at your house or not at his
house
it has to be at a restaurant yeah do you
know what the reason is for
that yes because he uh
doesn't want to be hemmed in
by uh you know societal
norms which means when you're invited to
dinner you stay
through dessert you know
he gets halfway through if he gets any
kind of
adjective he's up and out he wants to be
so he can't do it in a restaurant he can
we went out to dinner
i think it was woody harrelson uh pete
fairley
and myself and maybe someone else we're
going to meet larry for dinner
we were all together in the afternoon
and it was sounded like great fun
so we all get there even a little early
so uh
and the maintenance says well mr uh
david is uh seated over there and we we
show up and he is literally
halfway through his entree what he's
already ordered
because on a whim he's decided i think
i'll have more
fun if i go uh call this lady friend i
know
or something yeah you know well i don't
he's right
you know but nevertheless no qualms
about
totally blowing off any kind of right he
wants to he knows that in a restaurant
he can say
i'm done i'm out yeah i'm gone and he
can do it
10 minutes in throw in his share and be
gone but you can't do that at someone's
house
so he's he's got the whole thing right
stop going to people's homes
[Laughter]
you know larry's character is someone
who's always saying the wrong
thing on his show you yourself have said
that you're prone to a faux pas
occasionally you're not a great word
yeah faux pas
yeah it sounds like a faux pas yeah and
it
it does actually i used to pronounce it
foax pass
and then i realized i someone corrected
me about a year ago
but uh yeah faux pas is a great word and
you seem like someone who if you did if
you made a faux pas was because you were
maybe trying too hard to be nice and
maybe said the wrong thing is that is
that where these come from
yeah it's that whole charming thing you
know um
yeah i uh i'm trying to think of the
i've done a couple of them
my favorite was pretty much first uh
first
several interview interviews i did for
cheers and it was
very heady and exciting somebody
actually
asked you a bunch of questions and you
know appeared
to be so interested in everything you
were saying so
i was just full of myself and it was a
wonderful interview and i was charming
and
it was around the same time that dr uh
kevorkian
was doing a lot of uh assisted
suicides yeah it was very controversial
it was a big thing in the news at the
time yeah yeah
yeah euthanasia where you help people
pass on um and i i
went through my interview sailed through
and then he said one last question
what do you think of euthanasia and i
went
what you know i think they're pretty
much the same world over
and i could just see his eyes
now i understand everything i need to
know about ted
uh now you you know we were talking
earlier about
your your marriage your partner uh
mary you guys have been together 25
years now
together 27 yeah 27 married 25 okay
that's true i forget i've been married
19 together 21. um
and always a couple of years yeah i
always forget that you're supposed to
add in
yes you were with this person for two
years before that why aren't you
including that
and so i i've learned i've got to add
that in so yeah
but that's very impressive what do you
think is the secret to keeping
this relationship going
oh gosh i don't know um
telling the truth yeah and laughter
yeah um yeah i mean you work at it
but we we kind of made this deal early
on
uh we both had been married before and
been in relationships and
we we both before we met each other
right before
we're basically saying to ourselves well
we're just not cut out
to be in a relationship i can mess up
anything
so um it's kind of miraculous that we
found each other but we both
kind of felt like we don't want too much
drama
yeah in our life you know we'll do hard
stuff and we've done we've had
four teenagers and three grand kids in
life you know life comes at you and so
there's there is
hard stuff right by and large we kind of
went you know
let's do let's do 93
joyous fun together
and we'll do seven percent really hard
yeah and
we we tend to do that
that's a good that's a good formula i
like i
similar i think to what you're saying i
have found it helps that
my wife and i we both find ourselves
ridiculous you know that there's we
don't we don't take ourselves that
seriously and to me that feels like that
is the
that is the oil that sort of keeps the
gears moving is that
and and also i mean she thinks i'm
absurd and doesn't take me too seriously
and i think like okay
good mary has used those exact words she
finds me
ridiculous
look to be fair i you are you're no no
i know but it's great joy for me too i'm
not defensive about ridiculous and
shallow and all of those things it
brings me
a lot of happiness so please have at me
i i enjoy it myself
well i you know i did want to mention
i'm i'm first of all
very happy that you're doing mr mayor
and i
i almost thought it's almost unfair
the team you have behind this show
because you're involved and i've always
enjoyed
your work but then you've got of course
you've got
tina fey you know remember carlock i
mean this is just like
you've got the the best yeah i was
i didn't think twice i didn't even
before i even read this script i was yes
are you kidding right no i think if tina
fey called me up and said i've
uh i've written a great crime for you to
commit
yeah um you're going to go to jail for
25 years but it's going to be funny i
would do it
it would just be like especially if you
can credit tina yeah
i'm here no i still get to go to jail
but i get to say i'm in jail courtesy
of tina fey so uh it's on her and you
you must have worked with bobby
moynihan who's on our show yeah uh yes
i'm trying to remember when i'm trying
to think about when
because like you i've forgotten what
i've i have found the only way i can
exist is to leak
to delete large chunks of my life so
i from my brain it's the only way you
know the way they tell you you need to
remove stuff from
from your computer yeah when the great
jerry orbach
uh passed away um i remembered saying
god i wish i had met him and someone
said what are you talking about he was
on the show three times
and i had a delightful time and i have
revered him i loved him i just
too much when there's distance between
what you're forgetting it's excusable
my problem is you know at a party
in the beginning meeting somebody and on
the way on the way out
you know going how do you do how nice to
meet you
yes and they went we met five minutes
ago
that's when you learned to never say
nice to meet you
yes great to see you or just
hey
you're coming across a little high on
that one
hey that's more of the woody harrelson
high that uh that i would expect one of
the things i'm enjoying that i can
relate to
is that your character uh has a teenage
daughter
and so you're trying to relate to her
all the time
you use jen's gen z slang
and i can relate i have a 17 year old
daughter
and i try um i've learned that my
attempts
she enjoys the attempts at trying to
relate to her because i'm so wrong
so much of the time the same with my 15
year old son but
they they enjoy that but i think that's
a great comedic dynamic
for your character me too me too i'm i'm
i'm
late i'm not only oblivious to
the the new whatever uh phrase
uh i'm also i when i do come to the
party i'm like about
eight or nine years late so i'm just
starting to say things like
oh snap and i just love it
i totally get it's a great phrase yeah
it's not really cutting it anymore i'm
even further behind you
i'm saying word up word up which i think
is the 80s
uh and i'm raising the roof occasionally
i'm going
the other way i'm i'm going to be holy
me too
i've become my mother and my father
basically
and you know what i think we should be
uh challenging them
you know there's we have jargon whipper
snapper
there you go your little whipper snapper
[Laughter]
tell me what that is 17 year old guess
what
ted no one has said that in your
lifetime
[Laughter]
you're going back to the 1920s now so
yeah
well uh congratulations on mr mayor
season finale
airs this thursday at eight on nbc
i'm excited for the next season and uh
ted
truly uh one of my favorite people to
talk to thank you so much for doing it
it's a pleasure to be with you i hope
you're all well yeah and i don't know
who put you in that
one car garage
it does right we're in a
we're in a rental in vancouver
it's a new build i mean there's
literally
nothing in the shelves look at that
it's it's totally blank walls we had to
put our grandkids
uh little paintings up with scotch tape
on the wall
no it it really does look uh like you
got
you went to check out a new storage
space and you got locked inside
and basically there's some truth in
there then you decided i might as well
talk to conan while i'm here and talk
about mr mayor
hey ted my best uh to marry and uh and
to you have a good time up in
and and stay safe and uh let's get let's
get through this nonsense
yeah take care take care ted thank you
that was spectacular that was great
thank you bye